every single day that we release
thousands of of illegal immigrants into
our country we know that they're never
going to leave they're they're going to
be here to stay here is National border
patrol council president Brandon Jud
detailing the abject disaster happening
at our border right now what Authority
do you guys have to deport who can you
Deport or is it just largely at this
point just in processing and handing
notices to
appear nobody nobody what we do is we
take individuals into custody we process
them for deportation proceedings but
then we turn around and we release them
and what what that does is that allows
them to travel wherever they want in the
United States it also allows them to
disappear into what Obama term the
shadows of society that's when they
don't show up to their Court appearances
all of these people know that they have
a very small chance of actually
receiving Asylum by an immigration judge
they know that that's not going to
happen so they don't show up to their
court appearance so every single day
that we release thousands of of illegal
immigrants into our country we know that
they're never going to leave they're
they're going to be here to stay and
then when you look at the the how long
it's going to be before they even see an
immigration judge right now we're
looking at 7 years before and all they
have to do is come here get married have
a child you know there's different ways
that they can they can then ensure that
they're going to stay our system is
broken and the only thing that this
Administration talks about when they
talk about immigration reform is Asylum
I'm sorry is is uh amnesty they're never
talking about the actual policies that
will allow us to secure the border from
here going to the Future when you hear
that do you believe in the system do you
believe that the federal government is
doing the right thing at our border
you've got border agents literally
saying hey we're letting people in we
process them and then we know we just
let them out into the country and they
don't show up for their hearings because
if they show up their hearings they
might be kicked out so instead they just
Infiltrate The the country so when Elon
Musk posts a pin tweet Shining Light on
that that is good because he is trying
to say hey I'm an American we have a
problem here in America and the system
again do you believe in yourself or do
you believe in the system the system is
failing but there are some people I
would say Seth McFarland on the covid
front uh Sam on going after Elon it's
sort of you are running cover for a
system that is failing